your dad died tragically when you were
like five years old maybe yeah
which is awful and and he was a
successful actor in in england
very well known like a super famous guy
in england super i cannot stress to you
how famous he was in terms of
it being the 70s and there being maybe
three television channels
and he was in
you know two or three of the most iconic
comedies of the period and everybody
loved him you know he was just
incredibly beloved and
died very suddenly and
heart attack
heart attack at 31 which was 31 years
old you lose and you're five and you
lose this this charismatic father yeah
that i mean awful and and in terms of
how famous he was it was i remember
confusing
when john lennon died and when my dad
died because people were standing in the
street with the evening paper sobbing on
both occasions and i
i can't remember which version of that
is which because they were very similar
it was really really intense but only in
england so yes obviously john lennon
impacted absolutely every country in the
world my dad
it was it was very much england did your
mother remarry she did yeah she met my
stepdad uh when i was nine and
he was a director and moved in with my
mum and brought his
enormous amount of children which i was
kind of shocked by
and uh
and yeah and it's great and they're
still together so oh no kidding
yeah he must be blown out by your
success you know he's wild i really
lucked out with him he's the best i mean
we had some you know rough couple of
years getting adjusted
but um
no one's been a bigger
bigger champion like i really do feel
lucky that
i got you know got to cuckoo in to that
a rough couple of years meaning when
your mom first meets him and marries him
and you're like hey you're not my dad go
[ __ ] yourself i never said you're not my
dad and ever
but i definitely had that thing of like
i felt like i could see it coming so he
like sent my mother a book and i
remember going okay and i was nine
and i brought her this package because
you know it's pretty exciting when a
package arrives
and i she was in the bath and i brought
this package and went you've got a
package and then she opens it up and
looks at it and goes oh and i'm like
what and she goes oh this this you know
this director i just worked with he sent
me this book and i'm like he wants to be
with me once he fancies you he wants to
date you no no no i knew it
right um and so i just sort of felt like
this kind of inevitable and you know i
was at that age where i you know i'd
been on my own with my mum for a few
years and
you know i was at that age where you
know boys were just gross and scary and
you know not only was he one but he also
had
four sons and two of them were kind of
around my age and
they were really like
you know i was kind of a sort of
you know
pony riding clarinet playing
posh girl and they were [ __ ] rough
my brothers and you didn't want to be
hanging out with those guys i was
terrified like
i was kind of impressed by them but also
kind of terrified because they were you
know they
i had kind of a little posh voice and
they were very like you know london
accent and
said a lot of rude words and you know
it was a really big culture shock but
actually for me it was great because i
god knows i might have been an
insufferable
um
little preg if i'd stayed just on my own
but i did i learned how to have to you
know
i had to learn how to to sing or swim a
bit and
and and very much ended up being really
close with them and
um to rub the corners off each other a
bit in a way that i think was probably
good even though i don't think any of us
would have necessarily chosen that at
the time